تعزيز الانتشار حول الصين وكوريا الشماليه
هدف يبدو في خلفيه زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لكل من كوريا الجنوبيه والفلبين
وما صاحبها من تدريبات واتفاقات زياره
اوستن للمنطقه هي السادسه خلال عامين
وقرات في كل من بيجين وبيونج يانغ كمحفز
لمزيد من التوتر الاقليمي والعوده لاجواء
الحرب البارده تتمسك الولايات المتحده
بعقليه الحرب البارده ذات المحصله الصفريه
وتعزز انتشارها العسكري في المنطقه وقد
ادى ذلك الى زياده التوتر وتقويض السلام
والاستقرار بدورها علقت كوريا الشماليه
على المناورات الامريكيه مع الشطر الجنوبي
معتبره اياها سياسات عدائيه امريكيه وقال
بيان للخارجيه في بيونغيانج ان وعود اوستن
بنشر ما وصفها باصول استراتيجيه امريكيه
تفضي لتحويل شبه الجزيره الكوريه لترسانه
حربيه ضخمه ومنطقه حرب عاليه الخطوره في
العاصمه الفلبينيه عززت الولايات المتحده
وجودها العسكري باتفاق يرفع عدد القواعد
الفلبينيه المتاح استخدامها للقوات
الامريكيه من خمس الى تسعه بعضها قريب من
مياه متنازع عليها
ويسرنا ان نعلن ان الرئيس ماركوس قد وافق
على منحنا اربعه مواقع اضافيه في اطار
اتفاقيه التعاون الدفاعي المعزز ليصل
العدد الاجمالي للمواقع الى تسعه انا ممتن
للرئيس ماركوس لهذا القرار تحدث وزير
الدفاع الامريكي عن التصدي لما وصفها
بالانشطه المزعزعه للاستقرار في المياه
المحيطه بالفلبين بما في ذلك بحر الفلبين
الغربي واستمرار الصين في مزاعمها غير
المشروعه هناك وفق قوله
تتحسب الصين كثيرا لما ترى انه قوس متنام
حولها من القواعد الامريكيه في شرق اسيا
في اليابان مثلا وجود عسكري امريكي منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه هو الاكبر خارج
الاراضي الامريكيه بما يجاوز خمسين الف
جندي كما تعد كوريا الجنوبيه الثالثه اكبر
مستضيف للوجود العسكري الامريكي بعد
اليابان والمانيا وبها قاعده هانفرز
الكبرى عالميا مساحه وعدد قوات
التوطيد الاحدث للنفوذ الامريكي المتاخم
للصين تمثل في الاتفاق الاخير مع الفلبين
والتي لا تبعد عن تايوان
1200 كيلومتر في المنطقه ايضا اندونيسيا
بجزرها الكثيره وتسعى الولايات المتحده
لاستمالتها رغم النفوذ الاقتصادي الصيني
الضخم بها